welcome back to Earth
the MCU kicks off phase five with its
highly anticipated new series secret
Invasion centering around none other
than fan favorite Nick Fury
it is so good to see you so let's break
down episode one and yes there are Major
Spoilers to come so this is your
official warning all right the first
episode sees Nick Fury return home for a
less than happy reunion as he and his
team face a scrub terrorist attack in
Moscow
I mean this as a friend Fury
go back to your space station you're in
no shape for this fight that lies before
us the series welcomes new cast members
Olivia Coleman as Sarah Sinclair Emilia
Clarke as Taylor's daughter Gaia and
sees the return of Ben Mendelson as
Talos as well as Kobe smolders as the
Beloved Maria Hills here's one of you
nah
it's one of them whose return Is
tragically short-lived plot twist the
scroll attacker shape shifts into a Nick
Fury look-alike and kills Maria Hill
Point Blank
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
the episode ends with Hill dying in the
real Nick Furious arms amid the
explosive destruction all around them
[Music]
[Applause]
a shocking ending to say the least Ray
Hill was a big part of the MCU since her
debut in 2012's Avengers so this could
mean we can expect secret Invasion to
make even bigger changes to the future
of the MCU meanwhile I caught up with
Samuel L Jackson about the series who
spoke about the great opportunity to
further dive into the character of Nick
Fury
is always wonderful to find out new
things about a character or be given the
opportunity to explore uh other aspects
of a character that you think you know
or people think they know so what did
you think of the first episode of secret
Invasion and who is likely to secretly
be a skrull in Disguise let us know in
the comments section below